[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime la complexité j'adore la
complexité alors là j'ai perdu combien
personnes dans la femme à moitié minimum
non c'est vrai aujourd'hui quand on veut
vendre quelque chose quand on veut
vendre une idée on vous dit c'est simple
c'est intuitif même la phrase que je
préfère fait même un enfant de 4 ans on
peut le faire dans la même phrase on
postule que nous les adultes on est des
imbéciles et que l'enfant de 4 ans a un
cerveau de colibris et moi j'arrive sur
cette scène ce soir et je fais une
déclaration d'amour à la complexité
alors suis encore plus ambitieuse que ça
passe que dans les minutes qui viennent
mon intention c'est de vous la faire
aimer cette complexité seydoux faire
comprendre qu'elle n'est pas votre
ennemi mais quel est votre allié alors
comment ça il était une fois une petite
fille de 8 ans qui était né orléans mais
qui disait qu'elle était née à new york
on va la refaire j'avais 8 ans et je
suis allé voir mes parents et je ne suis
pas né en riant je suis née à new york
non pas celle là mes parents n'ont rien
à voir avec cette histoire donc cette
fois ci on la refait alors je ne sais
pas s'il y en a parmi vous qui au 6ème
new york et dans ce cas là vous avez vu
manhattan de woody allen et vous rendez
compte que je suis en train de faire une
sorte de pastiche du début de manhattan
quand le narrateur et 7 commencer on
sait pas trop si c'est son film ou un
livre
donc on a refait voilà j'avais 8 ans
j'étais né à orléans mais je voulais
absolument être né à new york parce que
je m'ennuyais
on vous me direz c'est normal de
s'ennuyer quand on est enfant
les pieds disent même qu'il faut qu'un
enfants s'ennuient or à dire vrai je
n'avais pas vraiment de raison de
m'ennuyer
j'adorais lire donc viser beaucoup avec
ma soeur de 11 mois de plus que moi au
regard des goldorak on jouait aux billes
j'avais des parents jeunes c'était
plutôt cool mais je m'ennuyais est le
summum de l'ennui pour moi c'était
l'école l'école c'est l ennui profond
total
tout était trop simple voilà et puis
dans le summum en fait c'était pas
l'école c'était le chemin pour aller à
l'école ou pour revenir de l'école tout
le temps mais monsieur m'a mais quel
ennui
je me disais ya bien un endroit sur
cette terre où il se passe quelque chose
comme dans les bouquins jolie et j'avais
décidé que c'était new york parce qu'à
new york
ce n'était pas une ville c'était la
ville et dans une ville il se passe
tellement de choses
une ville c'est un concentré des
possibles en déjà généralement une ville
c'est un endroit extraordinaire
bon évidemment la baie de rio la baie de
san francisco mais sans aller aussi loin
amsterdam où même les méandres de la
tamise les méandres de la seine c'est
magnifique
et puis une ville aussi fait une balade
dans l'histoire je ne sais pas si parmi
vous il y en a qui sont venus à pied par
exemple depuis notre dame
voilà vous êtes dans le paris médiéval
fait une petite boucle par de marais
vous voyez quelques fenêtres à meneaux
ça y est c'est la renaissance
et puis tout à coup les beaux hôtels
particuliers xviie xviiie et on est dans
le deuxième
et puis ça y est là le paris d'haussmann
les grands boulevards grand magasin en
une demi-heure fait une incroyable
balade dans huit siècles d'histoire
est ce que je préfère moi par dessus
tout dans une ville c'est cette espèce
de mélange incroyable entre l'ordre et
le chaos alors l'ordre évidemment les
façades bien aligner les beaux espaces
publics tous à paris on est gâté la
voirie et puis des ordres le désordre
c'est vous c'est moi c'est nous quand on
marche vie parce qu'on est pressé où on
est là au contraire le nez en l'air
parce qu'on téléphone il embouteillages
monstres évidemment les embouteillages
monstres et puis mes bousculade dans le
métro mais ce désordre c'est pas que du
négatif
le choc dans la ville
ça peut donner et rencontres ça peut
donner des histoires totalement
improbable le choc
ça peut donner des projets d innovation
plein de créativité c'est pas un hasard
si la renaissance est né à florence où
je sais pas alors la révolution
industrielle à birmingham et plus près
de nous on peut dire que la révolution
numérique elle est née à san francisco
c'est ça une ville alors ça tombe bien
qu'ils aient tous ces chocs et toutes
ses rencontres dans les villes parce que
l'innovation de la créativité on va en
avoir sacrément besoin on va en avoir
besoin
parce que c'est dans les villes que se
joue la plus grande bataille du 21e
siècle
je parle de la bataille contre les
changements climatiques c'est là qu'on
va la gagner ou la perdre pourquoi pour
une raison très simple parce que c'est
dans les villes qu'on consomme plus de
70% de l'énergie qu'on produit pour se
déplacer pour se chauffer pour cuisiner
pour se connecter et c'est dans les
villes on aimait la plupart des gaz à
effet de serre et notamment le co2 et ça
ça va pas changer parce que vous savez
ce qu'on est en train de faire en ce
moment on est en train de construire un
deuxième monde urbain entre les débuts
la civilisation et l'an 2000 on a créé 3
milliards d'urbain en 50 siècles et dans
50 ans on va en ajouter 3 milliards
supplémentaires
on sera six milliards d'urbain en 2050
alors vous me direz il ya des gens pour
s'occuper tout ça
les urbanistes les gens qui s'occupent
d'énergie les élus ils vont réussir
on va les laisser faire vraiment juste
un exemple
l'exemple des déplacements qu'on fait
entre les lieux où on habite et les
lieux ou au travail on étudie on se
forme les déplacements domicile travail
ces déplacements ne cesse de s'allonger
depuis 40 ans on habite toujours plus
loin du lieu on travaille voyez aux 75
ce qui est en blanc ou pal c'est les
gens qui travaillent dans la commune où
ils habitent et plus et rouge puis c'est
loin ça c'était 2008
c'est une enquête qui a lieu tous les
dix ans je peux vous dire que les
chiffres de 2018 ont pas du tout changé
et ça c'est l'ile-de-france mais vous
pouvez faire la même chose pour toutes
les grandes métropoles du monde
on ne cesse d'habiter toujours plus loin
de l'endroit où on travaille alors
quelles réponses sont apportées à sa
jusqu alors d'apporter une réponse qui
s'appelle l'étalement urbain mais
l'étalement urbain vous comprenez bien
que ça peut pas continuer comme ça c'est
pas soutenable du point de vue
environnemental ou économique
du point de vue environnemental parce
que étaler la ville toujours plus ça
veut dire artificialisés les sols et ça
pour la biodiversité c'est
catastrophique
l'étalement urbain ça veut dire que si
on habite toujours plus loin
eh bien on va toujours plus utiliser la
voiture ça veut dire aussi que quand on
habite plus loin et plus de place dans
construit des logements plus lent plus
grand donc on dépense toute énergie et
puis du point de vue économique non plus
ce n'est pas soutenable
il suffit de regarder l'actualité vont
comprendre ce qui se passe en fait quand
on y réfléchit ce qu'on a fait jusqu'à
lors c'est que chacun dans son domaine a
fait ce qu'il avait à faire ce qui
s'occupait de logements se sont occupés
logements à construire des logements
ceux qui s'occupaient d'infrastructures
mobilité l'ont fait chacun a fait son
dans ce qu'il avait à faire mais vous
comprenez par exemple je décide de me
faire construire une maison aujourd'hui
tu peux aller voir un architecte qui va
choisir toutes les technologies pourra
même être à énergie positive
cette maison mais c'est pas son rôle de
dire où est ce qu'on va l'implanter
cette maison
c'est pas son rôle de réfléchir aux
liens entre le logement la mobilité
l'énergie ce n'est pas son rôle
et vous imaginez que si nous 3 milliards
nouveau urbain font pareil ça passera
pas donc il va falloir prendre les
choses à bras le corps et prendre les
choses à bras le corps ça veut dire
d'abord cessé de croire qu'on peut
trouver des solutions simples à des
problèmes complexes
bon alors voilà ma complexité la
complexité on va l'appliquer au cas que
je viens de mentionner domicile travail
vous comprenez que pour résoudre cette
question la question universelle je le
rappelle pour résoudre cette question là
il va falloir regarder les formes
urbaines
est ce qu'on veut des villes plus
compact plus denses ou toujours plus
établis il va falloir regarder nos
rythmes de travail
est-ce que ça a un sens d'aller
travailler tous au même moment dans des
endroits qu'ils consentent les emplois
il va falloir regarder aussi du côté
économique
il va falloir regarder aussi peut-être
du côté des représentations des
perceptions
aujourd'hui l'image majoritaire c'est la
maison avec le jardin il va falloir
travailler sur tout ça sinon on
n'arrivera pas et moi ce qui me plaît
dans la complexité justement c'est qu'il
faut jongler avec trois quatre cinq
dimensions et au fond quand on y
réfléchit la complexité la vie c'est
exactement les deux faces d'une même
chose la vie est complexité regarder
n'importe quels organismes cellulaires
de base ceci est un chef-d'oeuvre de
complexité regardez nous les êtres
humains on et de la complexité sur
pattes
du point de vue physiologique du point
de vue psychologique ça fait jamais que
quatre ou cinq mille ans que les
artistes essaient de rendre compte de
cette complexité et franchement c'est
très bien comme ça est ce que vous avez
envie d'être simplifiée vous déjà quand
on y pense mais qu'on est petit on
essaye de nous assigner dans des cases
dans des catégories on sait la société
mais c'est mène notre entourage
on en sait quelque chose quand on est
une femme peut-être moins dans ce pays
et la plupart du temps quand on est une
femme voilà on fera t-elle type
n'aura-t-elle type de vie tel type de
carrière on est censé agir de telle
manière
moi même quand j'étais cette petite
fille sage de 8 ans
justement j'étais la bonne élève et donc
j'étais la bonne élève qui parce qu'elle
a des bonnes notes partout va faire des
études scientifiques parce que quand on
aime bonnet avons fait des études
scientifiques
ben j'ai dit non afin de la première
j'ai dit oui très bien ok maths physique
ça marche c'est pas un problème pour moi
mais c'est pas ça qui m'intéresse moi ce
qui m'intéressait c'était les mots
c'était travaillé sur l'histoire des
mots la forme des mauves qui
m'intéressait c'était la littérature qui
était le lien entre le langage de la
pensée c'est tout ça qui m'intéressait
donc c'est ça que j'ai étudié et puis
après quand j'ai fait ces études là j'ai
ressenti le besoin pour comprendre le
monde dans lequel vivait m'étais juste
après la chute du mur de berlin te bats
j'ai besoin de comprendre les concepts
diot politique d'économie de politique
donc j'ai bifurqué
je me souviens à l'époque le directeur
d'école par laquelle j'avais été reçus
me dit mademoiselle vous préparez une
carrière baroque
j'ai répondu ça tombe bien j'adore le
baroque et au delà de la réplique d'une
fille de 20 ans assez énervé il faut
lire par cette réflexion je m'aperçois
aujourd'hui qu'il n'avait pas totalement
tort au sens où oui le baroque a essayé
de rendre compte de la complexité de la
vie et c'est pour ça que j'adore ça
alors la complexité je vais assumer j'ai
continué mon chemin alors c'est vrai que
je rentre à jamais dans les casses à
chaque fois quand j'ai travaillé dans
une entreprise
gd dans ce qu'on appelle les fonctions
transverses parce qu'il n'est pas la
case et tant pis voilà j'étais l'ovni de
service et puis ça m'allait bien
et aujourd'hui sur les villes tu te dire
que j'ai trouvé un objet passionnant
vous savez il ya des urbanistes des
architectes qui parle de metaboli urbain
on parlait d'acupuncture urbaine n'a pas
besoin de tout refaire sa teinte fois il
suffit d'agir sur certains endroits de
la ville comme on agit sur certains
endroits du corps la voyez je pense
fondamentalement aujourd'hui pour
résoudre les grands problèmes
j'ai parlé du changement climatique mais
je pourrais aussi vous parler de la
congestion
je pourrais vous parler de comment on
construit du logement
bordas bhl dans les villes en croissance
comment construire du logement pour que
non seulement les personnes à revenus
faibles mais aussi les classes moyennes
ne soit pas chasser des villes et bien
aujourd'hui pour résoudre ces sujets là
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et moi c'est
ce que je fais c'est qu'on met autour de
la table des urbanistes bien sûr des
géographes des philosophes mesure dit on
va mettre des datas scientist on va
mettre des mathématiciens on met des
anthropologues des ingénieurs parce que
chacun va arriver avec son morceau de
solutions c'est exactement comme
rembrandt
vous savez ce tableau la leçon
d'anatomie
qu'est ce qui nous dit au fond il nous
dit que pour construire la médecine
moderne
il ya des personnes que dix septième
siècle se sont dit eh ben on va se
mettre à plusieurs autour du sujet on va
chacun arrive avec notre vision de ce
sujet et on va dépasser les limites qui
jusqu'àlors nous empêcher d'agir
il va c'est exactement comme ça
aujourd'hui qu'il faut qu'on fasse pour
résoudre les grands problèmes urbains
alors suis sûr que dans vos domaines
multiples ou aussi vous avez à faire la
complexité dans notre vie mam notre vie
personnelle
la complexité les quotidiennes je suis
sûr que vous aussi une petite voix qui
en vous vous dis oui
la simplification c'est peut-être une
voix mais au fond c'est une voie sans
issue et d'une certaine manière je vais
oser le paradoxe la complexité c'est un
chemin plus riche plus créatifs et plus
simple alors ce que j'ai envie de vous
dire ce soir c'est osez osez la
complexité osé considérer que vous avez
ou que vous êtes une brique de solutions
osé faire je crois que les marguerite
yourcenar qui disait ça dans son journal
des mémoires d'hadrien il faut être
comme le peintre vous savez le peintre
pour bien appréhender son objet pour
bien appréhender un paysage il tourne
autour de son chevalet et nous en fait
face à la complexité c'est ce qu'il faut
qu'on fasse osella cette complexité et
ça peu importe que vous soyez né à paris
à orléans ou à new york comme moi
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]